quelques 3000 suspension de soignants
non vaccinés annonce ce matin du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand et
ce au lendemain de l'entrée en vigueur
de l'obligation vaccinale en typo
évident pour les soignantes des
suspensions temporaires selon le
ministre de la santé elles concernent
essentiellement du personnel des
services supports très peu de pouce
blanche
hier quelques 3000 suspension sur 2,7
millions de salariés essentiellement du
personnel des services supports très peu
de blouses blanches un grand nombre de
ces suspensions ne sont que temporaires
et en réaction à la menace du
gouvernement les soignants se sont
mobilisés ils étaient une petite
centaine ce matin réunis devant les
locaux de l'ap-hp une protestation
contre l'exclusion des personnels
soignants a encore hésitants à se faire
immuniser au delà de la perte des
salaires les agents risquent de manquer
au bon déroulement des soins et de
pousser à l'hôpital à fermer des lits
réaction
on est dans un principe de contraintes
de vaccination sans convaincre et
maintenant
depuis le15 combler sanction de
suspension sur des agents qui d'ailleurs
ont été au front pendant plus d'un an et
demi qui sont indispensables dans les
services et donc la sq ont dénoncé qu'on
va dénoncer ces on va demander aucune
suspension notamment pour afin déjà de
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des lits
et l'offre de pinceau ouvert puisque par
ricochet les responsables qui sanctionne
et qu'ils suspendent vont appliquer des
créatures de link mois sur l'hôpital
saint-antoine j'ai fait le tour un petit
peu fière et je voyais je constate que
de nombreux lits sont fermés on constate
que il va y avoir un problème pour la
prise en charge de nos patients des
patients qui ont attendus pratiquement
un an un an et demi avec cette crise
d'épidémie on leur a dit qu'on pouvait
pas les prendre en charge on n'a ni de
la chirurgie il ya des hauts des
services entiers qui annule des des
opérations parce qu'un manque
d'effectifs et là qu'est ce qu'on
propose à nos concitoyens on va les
laisser mourir chez eux après avoir été
impacté par sa course être vite ils vont
mourir de leur maladie chez eux